Amalia tiene todo listo para el
nacimiento de su hija que puede ocurrir
en cualquier momento junto con su marido
eugeni vivían en San Petersburgo y
llegaron a Argentina en enero de 2023
las consecuencias de la invasión rusa
Ucrania los convencieron de irse de su
país sobre todo cuando se volvió una
posibilidad que hugen y fuera llamado
para ir al frente
tenía miedo de dejarlo salir
esos son parte de un creciente número de
ciudadanos rusos que están arribando
Argentina según datos de la dirección
Nacional de migraciones en enero de 2023
llegaron cuatro veces más que en el
mismo mes de 2022 de hecho en la escuela
la cantidad de vuelos que están llegando
y en la cantidad de embarazadas y que
cada vez en los vuelos hay más personas
de nacionalidad rusa
tener un hijo argentino ayuda con los
trámites de residencia Julia Pepe la
lleva llegó mucho antes Hace seis años
en Argentina tuvo sus dos hijos es
influencer ayuda a los rusos que quieren
vivir en el país y creó una guía sobre
Argentina que vende en línea desde que
comenzó la guerra crecieron muchísimo
las consultas que le llegan a sus redes
sociales los rusos ven en Argentina un
buen destino para emigrar acá a rusos
pueden entrar Para 90 días y después
hacer residencia por acá por eso hay
muchos rusos además por supuesto de
querer alejarse de un país en guerra
como Amalia y Eugenia ellos hicieron
este viaje dicen para darle un futuro
mejor a su hija
para nosotros dos es importante que
nuestra hija crezca en una sociedad
saludable
y mientras Amalia y bugeni esperan el
nacimiento de su hija siguen llegando
Argentina numerosos ciudadanos rusos
alejándose del conflicto y de un país
que ya no es para ellos un lugar
adecuado para vivir